well one everyone loves charlie all the
guys are just gonna hate me because they
love charlie all the girls are gonna
hate Charlie because they like like me I
guess me and Thomas got together a
couple months ago and invited them over
because he was a photographer and he was
really nice and we got along and he's
always wanted to shoot is it go get her
and me and him we're just like planning
it out talking about it it's just like
things just like oh that's silly like
that would never happen and then we just
just went and did it I put down the
money
Thomas had Thomas's of age I'm not of
age so we we all got done we all got
everyone together and got the house dang
it what's going on you guys I'm going
live so if you guys would join I do is
post my profile first tik-tok ever made
it was like a vine like it was like
who's what musically it was horrible
I literally just sat there and danced in
front of the camera and dabbed at the
end I was I think that was it and then
the first video that kind of went wild
was like it was like a sad movie scene I
can't do this
[Music]
pretending just friends I think about
you all the time
do you think about my parents have been
supportive I've been doing this for like
five years so they've at first they're
just like my sisters would just nag me
they're just like you're never gonna
make a career out of this anything like
that I was just like like go away like
I've got it I've got to go far I've
always wanted to like famous little
little child my parents knew nothing
about it really
my parents had offers for me and my
sisters to be like child models but
turned it down because they wanted us to
have like the proper schooling their
teachers they want us to do all the like
proper schooling but they became more
accepting of me going into online school
because they really wanted me to pursue
my dreams but when I was like young they
were making the decision for me not
really I want to be like more of an
entrepreneur and then they start a bunch
of businesses and I think if you if you
make it far enough here I don't think
you have to never have to work a day in
your life again
a year from now getting into the music
space a little bit it's all private at
the moment so it's in the works
doing stuff in the fashion industry I
have a tasting fashion doing a bunch of
shows getting invited to I've been
invited to Milan Fashion Week Paris New
York a bunch of these
[Music]
we're like an edgier pop I'm gonna post
about a lot of like kpop I like uh if I
were to say in an American Way it'd be
sound a little bit like 80s I haven't
met them like that's like shooting for
the stars but that would be super cool I
like doing a lot I don't he's got a
better fashion taste I like I think he's
I think he's the best dancer in the
group in my opinion yeah and he reminds
me and most myself no I don't know how
to tape it I don't know yes I'm very shy
okay
being called a heartthrob it's just
weird to me that people like me because
back when I was in Middle School in like
early high school is just like why does
anyone like chase everyone says pursue
your dreams when you actually do it then
you get judged for it so I was getting
judged for a big time of school which is
fine I don't really care but now that
I'm out of the school space that pays
off because I don't have to deal with it
anymore like I could see the social
media comments but that doesn't mean
anything to me anymore because it's not
like physical one-on-one like someone
saying it to your face which hurts a lot
worse I read a lot it's just so I can
filter out like mean comments you know I
could just I could just delete some so
the people that actually come to my
posts because they love my posts don't
have to see the negativity on it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know everyone's talking about like big
things are happening or just want to
come over and stuff like that like
Charlie gotta meet her her favorite
human being and I think that's super
cool and I'm super proud of her she
didn't even care if I go into Super Bowl
she's just like oh I'm gonna say well oh
I'm also beating to a low and this
starts crying but when I told her that
she started falling at tears I was so
cute I live in like I think I shed it's
here I don't cry often so Thor was like
it was so cute kids love me all this
stuff cuz like her kids watch her I
think that's even cool not officially
it's exclusive we're not talking to
anyone else we really like each other
we just don't want to put a label on it
yet I wanna I told her I want to take my
time and make sure everything is right
for me before I make it official she
really stood out to me most people are
comfortable around me in the fact that
she was shy like showed character a lot
of character in her and I was like oh
this is like genuine like it's actually
I don't know it is really cute
like when I wear first one on her first
few dates is like something different
about her because most people have like
a lot of people people say that they
everyone's different but not that many
people have her personality in it and I
think it really stands out
[Music]
so there's a place called the Glen in
Beverly Glen this is what's called
bel-air area and it's like a kilo brunch
cafe afterwards we went back to my I was
staying with my manager at the time we
just kind of like kicked it there and
talked and from her house she could see
like the view of La I could just we're
just talking around like a fire around
the fireplace and then we went to the
movies I figure out a movie we saw but
then after that we went to the Grove one
Cheesecake Factory and that was a nice
no that's a that's a little that takes
time as well like I'm a very slow person
like I've taken my past relationships
very slow and I've had bad outcomes from
a lot of relationships but uh but for
that reason I want to take things a
little slower well like about him hunch
about a month and a half maybe we she
just like hey or do you want to be
exclusive is like about that's what she
said to me I was like yeah okay it's
just she was like okay we took a long
time because I first it was just like
yeah this is like fun poking jokes and a
little bit of flirting here and there
and then it really took off later
[Music]
honestly stop some fairy tale right here
like I don't know who first kissed that
forgot where we were I think we're on a
date in Santa Monica no I was with you
and then uh during that day with none of
us Whedon even film it or anything and
we were just like off in our own little
fairy land he was cute
Oh God oh yeah pop apart she gave me
most Emma
oh it doesn't really affect anything
because she's a part of the team
everyone loves everybody here we've
always been close to her and I cared a
lot about her during her path to success
Charlie and Dixie started coming over a
little bit and then they started coming
over more and more and with I became a
lot of a lot of Fame and we had to teach
them how to handle it at first which I
started getting a lot of ten she's like
I'm quitting social media I don't want
to start I don't wanna post anymore
people are so many me I'm just like
Charlie this doesn't happen to a lot of
people keep post and keep going you're
gonna you're gonna to do big things in
life you just can't focus on what they
have to say and like where she is today
[Music]
big time
yeah and they still do if she talked to
me about all the time I have to like
talk talk her through it I guess
everyone has their their own taste in
like haters me and her get it the most
everyone loves Charlie all the guys are
just gonna hate me because they love
Charlie
all the girls are gonna hate Charlie
because it like like me I guess and then
there's the people that just won't like
us for us I don't know something like
set them off so I think there's people
just don't like us there and there's
people just hate people because it's a
trend so they don't know everyone I
guess
[Music]
of course always will always be dancing
around
[Music]
sometimes we think of it together I
suppose we just do the dance sometimes
to just goof off I don't know it's it's
never taken really too seriously
I just kind of have fun I do feel
pressure but at the end of the day you
don't want to make it like too much less
organic otherwise it won't be you and
I've always been trying to just just be
you and that's what that's what my reps
are really supporting but like just like
ease it down a little bit but do do you
you know me
I do a lot of like rappy stuff some
people can't think I'm a cocky or
whatever I'm just like a nice guy like
guy like I don't want anyone to think
I'm I'm the bad guy or anything I I'm
I'm really nice guy that's all really
[Music]